hello everyone I hope you're enjoying
your Sunday as we are back at the Kuppa
Blanca saga we're back at the 1914
tournament of sound Peter Berg it's
Hotel capablanca with the black pieces
against his old rival Frank James
Marshall and it's not a pleasant place
to be as a couple Wonka just lost two
games in a row first against roaches
champion Emanuel asked her then again
Steve Bottari in that wonderful game
that we've seen in the previous video
and this is just I mean it's it's tough
to be in this mindset we I mean I can
only imagine winning the first part of
the tournament were being a point and a
half in the lead then going into the
second half of the tournament going
through four of the strongest players
without a single loss and then it you
know starts first a loss against Lasker
then against ours
and now imagine if you lose a game
against Frank James Marshall as well
it's the third game in a row that you
would lose so surely not the greatest
spot to be in especially since
capablanca said before the tournament
even started that he wasn't feeling all
that great but okay he said that during
the san sebastian tournament as well as
well in 1911 and he warned that so it's
hard to say if it matters but he also
held the rubenstein to be one of the
favorites Andrew wished and did not even
qualify for the second part of the
tournament so a lot of things to
consider here but again without further
ado Frank James Marshall with the white
pieces opens with d4 and we have ESA's
by kappa blanka the whole was defense
basically asking Marshall do you want to
now go to e4 and we can transpose into
the French defense which Marshall does
we have E for transposing into the
fringe defense d5 and now comes he
captures and d5 the exchange variation
of the French something you know you
never want to play meet al tal said that
you know it's a crime against chess to
play as it's considered to be a drawn
drawn weapon against the French but okay
it captures Sun d5 Knight to f3 and now
rush of the g4 just spinning that night
and we have h3 asking Kappa bunker do
you wanna immediately trade or do you
want to go Bishop to h5 with Bishop to
h5 by Capablanca and now Bishop to e2
the knight is no longer pinned Knight to
c6 and now Marshall castles with Bishop
to d6 by Capablanca
and not Knight to c3 Knight to G to e7
developing and now comes in Bishop to e3
and here an interesting move kappa
blanka plays f6 it's it's an interesting
move because it really limits the
mobility of this knight on f3 is you
know you can go to e5 or g5 and also a
Copa Blanca might be considering
something like Queen d7 queenside castle
and then f6 will actually be a nice
support for the pushing of the pawns on
the kingside g5 maybe h5 g 4 and so on
so i useful move and one of the rare
occasions where it's actually okay to
play f6 but okay Queen d2 by Marshall
and now comes Bishop it back to f7
reinforcing the d5 square and also the
double shift was in the way of the pawn
pushing so perhaps also an idea rook we
have rook 81 now developing and now a
six by capablanca a three by Marshall
and Queen to d7 and now it's hard to say
our weather coupling look at Castle
kingside or Queen side but as a marshal
already Castle King side and capablanca
has this very nice set of chances are
that come along as king is going Queen
side with Knights to h4 by marshal and
now kappa blanka just castles Queen side
and as the Kings are now on opposite
sides of the board
it means well usually that it will be a
race Marshall will start attacking on
the Queen side and Coco Blanco will
start attacking on the Kings side so
first Marshall was for f4 it's a very
nice move out of the limits the power of
the Bishop on d6 but also prevents
capablanca from immediately going g5
which is a pretty big deal if you you
know cut it in the bud so to say maybe
the attack will not even happen and it's
impossible to immediately push it maybe
with an idea of starting with a pawn
sacrifice to just get things going as
the the best one f7 is you know being
x-rayed by this rook on f1 so you do
have to tend to that as well and now we
have Knight the b8 a very nice move by
Capablanca it's you know vastly von
Schuch said that the hardest move to
find is with the knight back so this is
not one of those cases but still you
know the knight will actually be
very useful there as you'll see Bishop
to g4 by Marshall this move pretty much
forces Bishop to e6 and Capablanca
really doesn't mind because his bishop
on f7 is well it's not as as great as a
Marshalls Bishop well the potential is
not so great so he couple one cadet play
Bishop d6 but instead this Bishop to g4
move immediately starting would be four
would have been better for white your
bishops are nicely played the why not
just try and bust open the Queen side
immediately but okay he has a different
plan Bishop g4 now you do have to block
there should be six is played and now f5
pushing coupling has a bishop back we
have Bishop to f7 and now what what
Marshall did here is he kind of blocked
the center but also he created a very
nice outpost for his night on East Egg
the idea is night e 2 to f4 to East 6
where couple monk will either have to
give up this dark square Bishop for
Marshalls night or he or he will have to
allow the night
this beautiful outpost on e6 so nice - E
- Marshall starts this plan of free
maneuvering the night over to e6 rook
dt8 and now comes Bishop to f4 the idea
is first you want to capture the bishop
and then trade and Marshall doesn't want
to allow couple Lanka to even trade the
bishop for the night here with Knight
eat the c6 and here comes Bishop
captures on d6 Queen captures and Knight
to a4 and now Marshalls a knight really
is coming to d6 but kappa blanka goes
night to d8 now i'm grabbing hold of d6
square again we have a move with the
knight back again it's not the hardest
move to find here you really don't want
to allow nice to e6 but you know it's
always a good to mention vastly if I
took as much as possible
c3 and now comes Knight B to c6 Knight B
to C 6 and the g3 now reinforcing the
night here and well it's now cap of
Lancaster and what does he want to do
Knight to a5 but playing c3 there are
now holes on the lights worse B 3 and C
4 ended the night is coming to c4 from
where the knight will harass the Queen
but also the b2
we have rook to e8 now Marshall captures
we have rook to e8 and now comes Knight
h2g2 Marshall starts REE maneuvering the
night and night the c4s plan by kappa
blanka and now a couple longer starts a
really nice plan first you have to do
something your queen is under attack
Queen to f2 by Marshall and now Queen to
b6 just you know simple moves increasing
the pressure thready screen capture some
b2 so you do have to do something about
it
look to be one not possible due to
Knight captures on a3 you can't capture
the rule can be one will be unguarded so
instead of this rook to be one Marshall
goes Knights to d3 and here most likely
this is everything everything designed a
cup of one can play Knight to c4 then
Queen to b6 and now Queen to b5 again
couple Blanca plays with with the utmost
simplicity but it's just very powerful
now the queen is preparing to capture
the knight on d3 one this knight moves
the thread is Knight captures on a3 and
it's not all that all that easy to
prevent this like you could go something
like rook to d1 but it's a it's a quite
a passive position for whites rook
so here marshal decides to go for an
active plan Marshall plays rook to e1
and he allows this little a nifty idea
by Capablanca and Capablanca goes for it
Knight captures on a3 opens up a
discovery against the knight on d3 we
have rook after Sonny 8 Bishop captures
on e8 and now comes Knight G to F 4 by
marshal defending this Knight and
welcome on cousin I did grab the a3 porn
but now it has to go back as Marshall
decided to defend the d3 night and now
his knight is definitely coming to e6 at
some point maybe even this night through
C 5 to 6 so we have Knight back to c4
and now Bush up to f3 increasing the
pressure against the d5 pawn and here
you could defend it for example with c6
but this wouldn't be all that impressive
do - quinta e - and now the queen is
infiltrating the position Bishop d7 now
comes g4 defending here and blacks
position is just a very passive even
though being up upon so after Bishop to
f3
we have Bishop to f7 Capablanca now will
defend not
with c6 but with Bishop to f7 and here
it's a bit different Marshall still goes
for Queen te - but now kaboom Lanka has
Queen to d7 he brings the Queen back to
help out with the defense and night the
c5 comes with an attack on the Queen
Queen to d6 and not finally Knight seat
to e6 and it took Marshall a long time
but finally the night is now you know
standing strong on e6 but capablanca for
the moment ignores it we have g6 a g5
trying to get rid of this night so after
this Knight moves
only then will couple [ __ ] capture here
as he doesn't want to allow the other
night to come to a 6 as well and here
capturing on poisson doesn't really do
anything a chapters g5 is still coming
so really white didn't achieve anything
here
so after g5 with Knight to d5 capturing
this pawn but it's everything couple o
couple Blanca calculated precisely
Knight captures any 6f captors on e6
Bishop captures on e6 not threatening to
capture here the knight on d5 so Bishop
to g4 with the idea that the bishop now
cannot capture as the king is still on
c8 so here you have to decide what to do
if you play something like f5 doesn't
really work due to Bishop captures on f5
and now bushel capture simply runs into
Queen EA to check and you're just losing
a queen here you have to block 97
checked in moves Queen captures and
you're I mean you're getting checkmated
at very soon on the other hand even
after Bishop captures even something
like Queen captures on g3 still king h1
and white is just better here you still
cannot capture you still can't capture
here due to again Queen - yay - check
you would have to go king b8 and then
you just lose the bishop here and
commercial captures and even after
Knight captures here it will it will not
help you
so after this Bishop to g4 we have Queen
captures and g3 immediately by
Capablanca delivers check King to h1 and
now immediately King to b8 here
Capablanca offers the bishop here we
have Bishop captures on e6 now comes
Knight captures on b2 and here Marshall
has a choice Marshall can capture the
knight on b2 and allow the squinty one
check King moves and now the
we'll pick up the bishop on e6 and we
will have this position where Marshall
has a knight and three points and
Capablanca has no pieces just the Queen
but six pawns
so that's a lot three points for the
night and this was most likely Marshalls
best bet to continue this game with
instead after couple uncle played night
capture son b2 Marshall played night to
e3 but also Marshall is still trying to
win this tournament I mean if he went
for this Queen captures and the line
which are shown check King g2 captures
he he wasn't very confident that he
would be able to win this game even
though up a piece so he tried a
different plan he tried Knights to e3
and here we have Knight back to a4 so
getting the knife out of the way but now
capablanca gets to save the night as
well
Queen to d2 now guarding the c3 pawn and
now Queen to f3 check King g1 but now
Queen to c6 with a double attack Queen
and Knight attack now the seeds reformed
but also the bishop is threatened so
here marshal was d5 defends the bishop
Queen captures and c3 Queen captures and
the Knight captures and here after all
is said and done you can see that we are
here playing this end game kappa blanka
is up for pawns but Marshall is up a
bishop so who you favor here I don't
know seems like black is the one to be
favored here a piece is a piece but all
of these pawns it's it's not gonna be
easy for Marshall Knights the g4 going
after the f6 pawn kappa blanka just
starts pushing the past pawn a 5 as
that's what you want to do with a which
passed pawns Knight captures on f6 and
now a 4 that passed pawn is you know a
very fast pawn Knight captures on h7
Marshall Groton grabs yet another pawn
and now ok he grabbed two pawns if he
can somehow you know keep everything in
check then his extra pieces is an extra
piece a three by Capablanca he just
continues pushing his passport and now
d6
you have to give up this pawn so the
bishop will now go guard the DA 2 square
we have C capture son d6 and now you
don't want to allow something like if
you play knight characters then d5 and
the pawn now blocks the bishops control
of the a2 square now black is just
winning so you can't do this
after C capture son d6 with Bishop to b3
you
one allowed this pond to block block
your view of the a to square and now
nice the e4 by kappa blanka you could
try immediately with a two but white
would just be very happy to give you the
piece bunch of captures not captures and
then we're playing this position where
you could capture on g5 white now has a
very fast pass point you have to pass
pawns but all in all it should be a draw
so Capablanca is not interested in
oversimplifying the position we have
Knight to e4 first bishop back to d5 but
it's not really a problem as there's
never any real danger of capturing the
night once if you capture the night then
a to just wins there's no way for the
bishop to get back anymore so b5 now
capablanca starts pushing the other pass
pawn as well we have nice to a fate and
now comes King the c7 now the King will
also help out with the pushing of the
pawns Knights the e6 width check King to
be six and now King to g2 Marshall also
starts bringing his King into the game
before now we have King to f3 now
attacking the knight with the King as
well so you do have to move it Knight d2
check King to e2 attacking the knight
you know it's a I mean it's not all that
difficult of an endgame but still it's a
nice in game it's a nice Sunday feel
free to pause the video and find the
winning idea for a copper Blanca here
you know just get into into the mood of
the game for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent pusher of the of past points
and for those who just want to enjoyed
show of course the move is b3 and now
it's not all that simple now you can no
longer capture because after Knight
captures the a pawn is just too fast so
here you could try something like Knight
d4 to try and block the pawns and now of
course you don't want to put a b2 and a
lot of Bishop to a2 but a to still just
wins once you capture Alessi you capture
here here you capture with the bishop
and then the pawn Queens immediately
recapture with the night and then you
just eliminate the defender of the a1
square you bring a queen into the game
of course black is just winning but
after b3 Marshall saw that there was no
any merit to this he decided to play 18
capture some d2 and now of course a2 is
coming you don't want to play b2
a bunch of data would be just terrible
for black so a 2 is what couple Blanca
played we have bunch of characters on b3
and not a one queen
so now capablanca has a queen against a
bishop and the night Marshall goes queen
bee through King de with Queen to f1
check King mustard before and now Queen
captures on h3 not overthinking at
capablanca just wants to mini-me
minimize any counter play for Marshalls
part bush up to d5 with Queen to f5 now
just you know preparing to push the
other pass pawn as well this is the
quickest way to victory not going for
anything too complicated King to c4 and
not g4 the passport is marching forward
we have King to d4 and now g3 and it was
in this position unmoved 61 that Frank
James Marshall resigned the game so this
is quite a victory for josé raúl
capablanca
in the in the second part of the 1914
tournament of some Peterburg especially
after the loss against loss current
Irish now having to face his old rival
with the black pieces it's not not the
greatest you know of things that need to
be done as I mean Marshall is quite a
fierce attacker a fierce player and when
you have to play with the black pieces
and you really want to win you really
want to catch up to last current Irish
after losing those two games in a row
definitely an important victory for a
couple Monica and it seems that Frank
James Marshall you know always comes
true for Capablanca he really just one
of the people most and most responsible
for Capablanca even appearing at the
1911 terminal so San Sebastian didn't
come back I want it and then of course
he was invited to the 90/14 tournaments
and Peter Berg just you know
and now after losing to him general
again a full point against Frank James
Marshall I just just great guy this this
Frank James Marshall yeah actually
resigned as there's no point in
continuing this whatever we play let's
say King C for not just Quincy to check
and the g2 is coming whatever you play
just you push it the black will have to
give up white will have to give up at
least a piece and now it's a queen
against tonight you could still hope for
some huge blunder but Marshall doesn't
do that he just resigns and a great
victory for Hosea Capablanca so we are
almost at the end of the 1914 tournament
in sung Peter Berg some of you say that
I repeated a lot that you all know
what's the name of the tournament and
the year of the tournament and while I
do understand that you know it will come
in very handy
you know maybe a week or a month or a
year from now when you will be telling
the great story of the 1914 tournament
in San Peter Berg you know to your
friends and family you know in in a
library or a bar then you will remember
it like of course those of you who are
older subscribers that this channel
still remember the final standings of
the 1959 candidates tournament but yeah
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you are still
enjoying the coverage of the Capablanca
saga like I said almost at the end of
this great tournament one more game
remaining in this turn it's a game
against cava Blancas well good friend
and future rival Alexander awaken it
will be quite the game so I hope you're
ready for it I would like to thank Brian
Quran Alan Davis Sarah Wright Jonathan
Miller Jonathan Miller and as Reviver
for a contribution to my channel think a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and I do have a
short announcement I will be starting a
weekly tournament very soon but more
about that in some of the next videos
thank you all and I will see you soon
have an excellent rest of your Sunday